- [Voiceover] In this video,
we're going to be talking
about conjugate acid-base pairs.
We're going to introduce the idea
of a conjugate acid-base pair
using an example reaction.
The example reaction is
between hydrogen fluoride,
or HF, and water.
So hydrogen fluoride is a weak acid,
and when you put it in water,
it will dissociate partially.
So some of the HF will dissociate,
and you'll get fluoride minus ions.
And then that dissociated H plus ion.
So this dissociated H plus ion
will get donated
to our water.
So water then becomes
H3O plus, or hydronium.
And so this process is
in dynamic equilibrium,
cause it can go forward,
and it can go backward,
and eventually, those two rates are equal,
and they're both happening
at the same time.
So in this reaction, we have
a couple things going on,
and we're gonna think about it
in terms of hydrogen ions being exchanged.
So if we just look at
the hydrofluoric acid,
and we look in the forward direction,
our HF is becoming F minus.
And it's doing that by donating or losing,
so I'll put a minus for losing a proton.
So our HF loses a proton
that forms our F minus or fluoride ion.
And then we can look at that same process
happening in the backwards reaction.
So if we look at the backwards reaction,
which is also happening,
the fluoride ion can pick up
or accept a proton from somewhere.
So it can pick up an H plus,
so I'll have a plus, H plus here.
And so when fluoride accepts a proton,
we reform our HF.
So we can see that HF and F minus
have this special relationship where
you can form one or the other
by losing or gaining a proton.
And we can see a similar relationship
between water and hydronium.
So, water here, we said water
is accepting a proton from HF,
so we see that water will gain a proton,
and that will give us hydronium.
In the reverse reaction,
hydronium can lose a
proton to reform water.
So, minus H plus.
So again we have these two species,
water and hydronium,
that are related to each other
by having, or not having, one H plus.
So in chemistry, we call these species
that are related in this way
conjugate acid-base pairs.
So the official definition,
or my official definition of
a conjugate acid-base pair
is when you have two species
that are related to each other.
Let's see, two species that
are related to each other,
related by one H plus.
In this case, we have HF and F minus
that are related to each
other by that one H plus.
And so HF and F minus are
a conjugate acid-base pair.
We also have water and hydronium,
which are also related by that one H plus.
So water and H3O plus are also
a conjugate acid-base pair.
You can probably tell from the name,
but whenever you have a
conjugate acid-base pair,
one thing in the pair will be an acid,
and the other thing will always be a base.
The definition of which one is the acid
and which one is the base
comes from the Bronsted-Lowry definition
of acids and bases.
So the Brondsted-Lowry definition says
anything that can donate an H plus,
so anything that will give
away an H plus is an acid.
So we can see that, in this case,
our hydrofluoric acid
is acting as the acid
in the conjugate acid-base pair.
And that means that fluoride
has to be acting as the base.
And that makes sense, because
the Bronsted-Lowry definition of a base
is something that will accept an H plus.
And that's exactly what it does
in the reverse reaction.
Your F minus will pick up an H plus
and go back to your acid.
So we can also look at water and H3O plus.
So here, water is gaining
a proton, or accepting it,
so water is acting as a base.
And in the reverse reaction, H3O plus
is donating a proton,
so H3O plus is acting as an acid.
The relationship between
conjugate acid-base pairs
we can write a little bit more generally.
So, if we represent
any generic acid as HA.
So this is our acid.
We said that a acid is
something that donates a proton.
So it'll lose the proton,
and when it does that, it
will form the conjugate base,
which is represented by A minus.
In the reverse reaction,
our base, A minus,
can gain a proton and remake our acid,
or conjugate acid.
So whenever you have two species
that have basically the same formula,
which we abbreviated here as A minus,
except for one has an
H plus and one doesn't,
then you know you have a
conjugate acid-base pair.
So let's look at some more examples
of conjugate acid-base pairs.
We saw above, HF, or hydrofluoric acid,
it's conjugate base is F minus.
So here HF is our acid, and
when it loses that proton,
we are left with F minus.
We saw in the same reaction
that water can act as a base.
So if water is our A minus,
if that water accepts a proton,
it forms the conjugate acid H3O plus.
So the example we've gone through so far,
HF, is for a weak acid.
But we can also talk about
the conjugate base of a strong acid,
like hydrochloric acid.
HCl is a strong acid,
so that means it completely dissociates.
So it gives away all of its protons,
and when it does that,
we're left with the
conjugate base, chloride.
So even though chloride
isn't particularly basic,
it's still the conjugate base of HCl.
And last but not least,
we're gonna go through two examples where
it looks like we might have
a conjugate acid-base pair,
but we actually don't.
So one example is, what
about the relationship
between H3O plus and OH minus?
If we think of our acid up here
being H3O plus, if we lose one proton,
we saw that its conjugate base is water.
If water loses another
proton, we get OH minus.
So the difference between
these two species here
is two protons instead of one proton.
So these two, hydronium and hydroxide
are not a conjugate acid-base pair
because they differ by two
protons instead of one.
And then the last
example we'll look at is,
we said that fluoride is
a conjugate base of HF.
So what about the relationship between
sodium fluoride and fluoride?
And so these two are also
not a conjugate base pair
because if we take our fluoride ion,
and it accepts a proton,
we don't get sodium fluoride.
They are related by a sodium ion.
So by definition, these two are not
a conjugate acid-base pair.
So in this video, we learned
that a conjugate acid-base pair
is when you have two species
and they have the same formula,
except one has an extra proton.
So the acid has an extra proton,
which it can lose to form the base.